(pensive music)
- [Narrator] When
President Biden test drove
a new electric vehicle from
Ford, he liked what he saw.
- This sucker's quick.
- [Narrator] But the industry
has a problem to solve
before consumers get
onboard with EVs: charging.
Experts say the concerns over charging
are holding many drivers back
from switching to EVs.
That's sending companies on a race
to improve the nation's charging network.
- It takes public fast
charging to sell cars.
People need the confidence to know
that they're gonna be able to do that.
- [Narrator] But building
this new fleet of chargers
won't be cheap.
- There's very much a
chicken or the egg problem
because you'll put chargers in the ground
but there's just not demand.
- [Narrator] Here's how charging
became the EV industry's bottleneck
and what some companies are going
to try and fix it.
(dramatic music)
Charging is a surprisingly complex issue
for the EV industry.
One of the main challenges
is that in many cases, it takes too long
to fill up the battery of a car.
The most satisfied EV owners,
according to J.D. Power,
are able to charge at home over night.
That can be done with the
regular plugs in your home
but charging this way can take days
to full up a standard range vehicle.
The industry calls this
level one charging.
Homeowners can upgrade
to a level two charger
but that can cost thousands
of dollars to install
in some cases.
Then there are drivers who
can't charge at home at all,
like many who live in apartments
and rely on publicly available chargers.
The research says
that this network needs improvement.
As of 2021, the US has roughly 41,000
of the faster level two stations available
to the public.
The Department of Energy says
that by 2030, the US will need 600,000
of these machines to meet expected demand.
Private companies like
Revel are stepping in
to try and get ahead of these issues
by installing even faster
level three stations.
This is Revel's first super
hub in Brooklyn New York.
It's stocked with a direct
current power station
to service level three chargers.
The industry calls these DC-fast chargers.
Paul Suhey, the company's co-founder,
says that this site is the
largest fast charging depot
in the Americas.
- New York City has a major problem
and the problem is charging infrastructure
just simply does not exist.
It is a challenge to
find a studio apartment
in New York City,
let alone a charging site
where you're talking about
skyscraper levels of power.
- [Narrator] Revel says
that its fast charging plugs
can provide 100 miles of
range in about 20 minutes.
The company believes
that its fast chargers
could ease the anxiety of EV ownership
for city dwellers who
typically have to pay
to enter a public parking garage
before paying again for their charge.
- There's no pay wall.
You can access a charger for free,
which is very unique in New York City.
The second thing is just a massive site.
We're talking 25 chargers in one location.
It's just a much better user experience.
- [Narrator] Revel isn't
the only company focused
on fast charging.
DC-fast stations are the
quickest growing segment
of the EV charging market.
Tesla pioneered this
technology in the 2010s
with its Supercharger network,
which has more than
25,000 stations worldwide
but Tesla's system
doesn't work with hardware
from other manufacturers
and that represents another
problem with EV charging.
Many of the systems on the
market are incompatible.
In the US, companies are designing cars
that use different
types of charging plugs,
which is creating problems
for people looking to fill up.
That's fairly different
from the customer experience
at gas stations.
In most cases, the nozzle at the pump
will fit the car.
That won't necessarily
be the case for EVs.
The industry is using
a standard plug shape
for level one and level two chargers
but there are three
different plug shapes in use
on the newer, faster chargers.
Experts say that aside from Tesla,
companies are moving toward
the combined charging system,
or a CCS.
But for now, drivers might need
to carry dongles to make sure
that their car works
with the charging ports
that they have find.
That's a problem that companies
like EVgo want to solve.
- Jonathan Levy, the company's
chief commercial officer
says that their technical team is working
to make their chargers compatible
with all EVs on the market.
- We're currently in a process
where we're installing hundreds
of integrated Tesla connectors
at EVgo fast chargers around the country
because they're more than half
the EVs being sold right now
and while other automakers
are bringing more models
to market and will continue to penetrate,
Tesla drivers and EVs using CHAdeMO
and EVs using CCS all
need access to charging.
- [Narrator] The company plans
to have installed 600 Tesla connectors
across its fleet by the end of 2021.
But in the race to make
these new, compatible,
fast charging machines,
the costs for companies and
consumers are adding up.
Industry experts say that
building out a bigger
and faster fleet of chargers
is going to cost a lot of money upfront
before consumer demand picks up.
Researchers say that an
installation of a level two charger
could cost tens of thousands of dollars.
But costs for the newer DC-fast stations
could stretch into the
millions of dollars.
To cover these costs, EVgo partnered
with a special purpose acquisition company
to quickly raise funds
but red tape is slowing down
the build out of its fleet.
- Cities and counties have
really been hurt a lot
on a budget basis across the country,
especially in COVID
and so if you have a part-time
permitting authority,
that can really slow things down.
When we think about how long it takes
to build a fast charging station,
it's anywhere from six to 18 months
with exceptions on either side of it
and it could be a lot quicker
if we were able to again
streamline some of this
and work on getting the flywheel spinning
in this ecosystem.
(lively music)
- [Narrator] Some lawmakers
in Washington believe
that the industry needs help.
- In answer to your direct
question, we have a deal.
- [Narrator] A bipartisan group,
including the president and many senators
are calling for $7.5 billion
to build a network of
chargers along highways
and in rural areas.
But even if public funding materializes,
the EV charging companies
have to navigate other bottlenecks,
like regulatory approvals
while the development costs pile up.
That could leave some EV owners searching
for a place to plug in for some time.
(pensive music)